predictors of a divorce is actually if
the woman out earns the man
oh i love that i actually love that i
can't like actually you love that you
don't think that's kind of shitty no i'm
like girl you you go get that you go get
a man like yeah you go get that like
really yeah like why is there like a
lack of empathy for ben it's not lack of
empathy but there is because like
they're they're breaking up a family a
lifelong commitment in a home and your
your reaction is
you go like go get that go get the bag
sister like i'm so happy for you
when that's actually a really like
that's a sad situation like your wife is
leaving you but then we could argue that
if a mom wanted it enough and wanted to
be enough then we could argue that right
but he could be enough but he he can't
because he's she out earned him like
that's that's what i'm saying so in this
case if it was possible for her why
isn't it possible him for him
if she could do it and make that money
why couldn't he i think there are times
where you make less money like yeah my
dad's in the top half a percent of
earners there there were times where he
was barely making any money yeah and my
mom stayed because she's a loyal [ __ ]
and so i'm